salut c'est hugo de la chaîne youtube le
tattoo aujourd'hui je suis avec brut et
on va parler d'une organisation de
défense de l'environnement ils
combattent des baleiniers il lutte
contre les maltraitances animales
mais ils ont aussi une réputation
sulfureuse
avec brut on va vous raconter l'histoire
de sea shepherd cette organisation c'est
avant tout son fondateur paul watson
alors lui la défense des animaux c'est
un combat qu'ils mènent depuis toujours
et d'ailleurs sea shepherd ça a commencé
comme ça les premières scènes horribles
dont il parle c'est notamment les
massacres de bébés phoques puisqu'il est
canadien et qu'il a été aux premières
loges
il dit que tout petit déjà il s'était
juré de tout faire pour y mettre un
terme
paul watson décide donc très vite de son
gaz et et ça commence en 1969 alors
qu'il n'a que 19 ans à ce moment il
rejoint les rangs d'une organisation qui
ne donnera plus tard greenpeace dans les
années 70 il a fait une première mission
donc contre les tests nucléaires
et ensuite greenpeace est assez
rapidement passé aux combats contre la
chasse à la baleine dans lequel paul
s'est de suite reconnu et investi pour
corruption de tous poils et est
considéré comme étant trop radicale même
au sein de greenpeace
la scission à la était vraiment consommé
au moment de la campagne contre la
chasse aux phoques en 1977 la fameuse
campagne où brigitte bardot est venu sur
la banquise avec des images d'elle qui
ont fait le tour du monde
et qui ont eu un impact extrêmement
positif pour les phoques à toute façon
maintenant ça suffit demandant qui est
révolté et écoeuré je les fais pour les
bébés phoques en me disant que peut-être
que le fait que je me déplace à l'est ça
allait faire un mouvement de foule de 12
le boycottage de ça il faut il faut
qu'il se passe quelque chose
lors de cette campagne la pole a saisi
le gourdin d'un chasseur de phoques qui
venait de fracasser le crâne d'un bébé
phoque et qui s'apprêtait à en tuer un
second donc paul a saisi le gourdin et
l'a jeté à l'eau et ça a été considéré
par la direction de greenpeace comme un
acte de violence destruction de
propriétés privées
donc ça a été considérée comme une
violation des règles de non violence de
greenpeace la la scission était
consommée il a été exclu de la direction
et du coup il s'est retiré complètement
greenpeace en dix ans dans ce cas je
vais créer ma propre organisation et on
ne se contentera pas de faire de la
protestation de prendre des photos on
interviendra
on est donc en 1977 et c'est la
naissance de sea shepherd est d'ailleurs
petite info sea shepherd en anglais ça
veut dire berger des mers et s'est
inspiré des bébés phoques qu'on appelle
blanchon parce qu'ils sont tout petits
tout blanc comme des moutons
bref passons la première grosse
opération qui a fait connaître
d'ailleurs sea shepherd et paul c'est
c'est le sabordage du baleinier pirates
le sirha qui tué des milliers de
baleines et monsieur et ensuite le cirad
a donc dû rentrer à quai difficilement
et il a eu à peu près un an de
réparations et quelques jours avant ça
sa remise en mer est là il a été coulé
par des ministres depuis ce 1er
sabordage sea shepherd affirme avoir
coulé une dizaine de bateaux comme vous
avez pu constater leur méthode c'est
l'action sea shepherd existent pour
pallier un manque crucial
il n'y a pas de police en haute mer paul
depuydt début milite pour une sorte de
création de casques bleus des mères qui
serait en charge de protéger le milieu
marin et ça n'existe pas en mer c'est le
far west au fur et à mesure des actions
polémique qu'a mené paul avec sea
shepherd
on a commencé à être
traiter de pirates mais de façon
péjorative par nos détracteurs et paul
qui est très taquin qui d'ailleurs est
massé la piraterie animé très bien ça ne
va pas être des pirates
on est des pirates de compassion au
service de la vie marine et on s'oppose
aux pirates braconniers qui détruisent
la nuit
notre
c'est que michael est
et donc il a revisité le logo de pirate
qu'il a remplacé les zoos humains par le
trident de neptune pour la symbolique la
combativité et le bâton du berger qui
symbolise la protection et dans le crâne
on a un cachalot et une baleine ya un
dauphin pardon en forme de ying et yang
et ça symbolise l'équilibré marin qui
dépend de la vie marine de toute façon
c'est clair pour embarquer sur un bateau
participant aux missions de terrain
en tout cas il faut être prêt à prendre
des risques c'est inhérent aux missions
parce que on s'attaque à des intérêts
économiques qui sont importants et qu'on
est face à des gens qui n'ont pas de
scrupules
[Musique]
c'est pas pour tout le monde et
d'ailleurs il ya plein de façons de
participer on n'est pas du tout obligé
d'aller sur un bateau à la coupe du
monde est ce qu'ils savent il sait on a
plus de bénévoles à terre dans des
structures locales qui s'investissent au
niveau local on a des gens en r alors si
intéressant à savoir c'est que si j'ai
peur qu'ils affirment qu'ils sont tout
le temps dans la légalité et qui
s'attaque en gros qu'à ceux qui
respectent pas les lois mais voilà comme
vous pouvez vous en douter leurs
méthodes ne plaisent pas à tout le monde
ils sont très critiqués par leurs
opposants mais aussi par des
organisations de défense de
l'environnement en fait les gens les
accuse d'être trop violent agressif
extrême et donc parfois contre-productif
je ne partage pas nos principales
structures oxydation pipeau
[Musique]
non
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça fait peur dit
un pays en particulier avec qui s'est
clairement tendues depuis des années nos
[Musique]
citoyens pour leurs attentats
d'un côté on astique shepherd qui se bat
contre la pêche à la baleine d'un autre
côté on a le japon qui pêchent la
baleine donc forcément ils s'entendent
pas très bien et d'ailleurs suite à ce
conflit le japon a émis un mandat
d'arrêt contre paul watson pour
plusieurs chefs d'accusation je vous
laisse y que je prends mon téléphone
parce que c'est très long entrée par
effraction sur un navire atteintes aux
biens entrave à l'activité imposer par
la force et coups et blessures
tout ça en rapport avec deux attaques
perpétrées contre des baleiniers
japonais en antarctique en février 2010
et c'est pas tout parce que à cause de
ça il a été mis sur la notice rouge
d'interpol depuis septembre 2012 alors
une notice rouge c'est pas un mandat
d'arrêt international
ça donne pas le droit à tous les pays du
monde de t'arrêter une fois que tu es
chez eux c'est plus complexe que ça et
d'ailleurs je vais vous citer la
description qu'on peut trouver
directement sur site d'interpol une
notice rouge c'est une demande transmise
par interpol à ses pays membres afin que
ceux ci détermine s'il peuvent détenir
ou arrêter une personne pour que le pays
hôte et rend puisse demander son
extradition
paul aujourd'hui habite dans le vermont
aux états unis il y aurait sans doute
pas de problème à ce qu'ils sortent des
états unis à ce qu'il arrive en france
le problème pour lui ça serait plutôt le
retour aux etats-unis passer la
frontière
il n'a pas du tout confiance en 30 le
risque ça serait que qu'ils soient
arrêtés des portes au japon pour être
concret en 2018 sea shepherd a mené 30
et une action à travers le monde que ce
soit en mer ou à terre ils ont notamment
lutter contre la pêche illicite en
italie au gabon ou encore en tanzanie
ils ont également réalisé une campagne
mondiale contre les déchets marins en
france par exemple il cherche à protéger
les tortues marines avec l'opération
nyamba à mayotte bref ils font quand
même pas mal de choses aujourd'hui on a
on a une flotte de douze nazir le
plusieurs c'est pas d'acquérir les
navires le plus dur c'est de les
entretenir et de financer le carburant
notre budget au niveau international il
est de l'ordre de 11 millions d'euros ce
qui est ce n'est pas grand chose en fait
si on arrive à boucler les fins de mois
on va appeler ça comme ça c'est parce
qu'on travaille avec 95% à peu près de
ratio de bénévoles
n'a à peu près dans le monde 1
une trentaine de personnes payées sur
les bateaux seuls sont rémunérés les
capitaines les chef mécano et les chefs
de pont sachant qu'ils se sont payé à
peu près trois fois moins que ce qu'il
gagnerait dans la marine marchande luka
modric
ellie goulding et les gorilles qui est
intéressant ce dont les développements
de ces dernières années c'est qu'on
travaille de plus en plus son
partenariat avec des gouvernements pour
intervenir dans les eaux territoriales
on est face à deux cas de figure donc on
a le café où il n'y a pas de volonté
politique
il ya des moyens ya pas de volonté
politique et il ya d'autres pays où il
ya une volonté politique mais il n'y a
pas de moyens c'est le cas de plusieurs
pays en afrique notamment avec qui on
travaille aujourd'hui et met à
disposition un navire en équipage et 40
ans d'expérience dans l'anti braconnage
pour aider ces pays qui ont la volonté à
protéger leurs eaux territoriales
même si il faut rester lucide il faut
rester humble aussi par rapport à notre
impact parce que c'est pas si shepherd
qui va sauver l'océan on n'a pas les
moyens de faire mais on est un exemple
de ce qu'il est possible de faire pour
agir à son niveau à brno et bribes harry
winston la sécu d'entre elles dont
maintenant l'océan c'est le premier
organe de régulation du climat
c'est notre première source d'oxygène
c'est le premier puits de carbone
et quand on dit aussi hein c'est pas
c'est pas la masse d'eau salée c'est la
vie marine
une autre chose et puis la culture
[Musique]
du coup vous l'avez vu sea shepherd même
de vraies actions sur le terrain mais à
côté de ça ils sont quand même critiqué
parce qu'ils sont jugés un peu trop
agressif
du coup il y en a qui les voient comme
des sauveurs des maires d'autres comme
de vrais pirates
à vous de vous faire votre propre avis
[Musique]